Here's an abstract specification
of a knowledge-based AI method for
doing configuration design.
The process starts with
some specifications.
These might be the specifications of all
the constraints on this configuration
problem, for example the constraints
on David's basement.
The output is an arrangement model,
a model of the arrangement of
all the components with the components
already known, for example,
the arrangement of David's basement.
In this matter, for
some configuration design,
we begin with some very abstract,
and perhaps partial solutions.
This abstract and
partial solution may be represented
in the form of a design plan.
So, an abstract and journal plan for
basements of houses.
Each plan specifies a subset
of all the variables.
We assign values to
the variables in that plan.
The plan is now complete.
A completed plan can now be refined and
expanded.
At the next lower level,
the plan specifies more variables.
We assign values to those variables.
Now that plan at the next
level is complete, and
we continue this iterative process until
we have a complete arrangement model.
As an example, if somebody was
building a residential home,
like David is doing right now, then the
abstract plan may deal with the number
of stories that the house will have.
Once we assign to the variable
number of stories,
then we get a more expanded and
refined plan where we have a plan for
each of the stories
including the basement.
For example, for the main floor,
there might be a plan which specifies
something about a kitchen area,
something about a living area,
something about a bedroom area.
As we assign values to the variables
that define the living area, and
the kitchen area, and the bedroom area,
this plan gets completed.
And now we might refine it further, a
more detailed plan for the living area,
for example.
This abstraction hierarchy is
a diagrammatic representation of this
plan's arrangement
from those abstraction.
I begin with the most abstract plan,
then I refine them and
expand them as I go down.
As I said earlier in
configuration design,
all the components are already known.
Nevertheless, in some cases it might
be able to also select the components.
So for example, I might not only
be able to reconfigure the TV,
I might also be able to
pick a specific kind of TV.
So this might be a TV in general and
a more specific kind of TV and
more specific kind of TV and so on.
Note that the arrows coming
here are two way arrows.
This is intentional.
In particular, let us look at the two
way arrows between the arrangement model
and the process of configuration and
the specifications and
the configuration process.
Once this process has
yielded an arrangement model,
then we can assess the arrangement model
and if needed go back to the process.
As an example,
the configuration process says that
the TV is 12 feet away from the couch.
And we assess it, and we decide
the couch is too close to the TV.
Then we can go back to the process and
say, make the couch more than
12 feet away from the TV.
That then becomes an additional
specification here.
And this is the meaning
of the two way arrow.
It is not just that we start with
specifications and the configuration
process works to satisfy them, but also,
as the configuration process works and
results in solutions,
we can evaluate those solutions.
And the specifications may change.
This is a very common
property of all design.
One of the major differences
between design and
problem solving is that
in problem solving,
the problem typically remains fixed
when we come up with a solution.
In contrast in design, the problem
evolves as the solution evolves.
The problem and the solution co-evolve.
So we start with a problem of satisfying
certain constraints, but as the solution
evolves, the evolution of the solution
results in the evolution of a problem.
As an example,
let us suppose that the configuration
problem is to configure the parts
of a computer processor so
that the processor can work
at a particular speed.
To do so, you come up with
an arrangement model, but
when you evaluate it,
you find that the processor overheats.
In that case, you may change
the specification and say that
the specification is not only that
the processor should be fast enough, but
also that it should not overheat.
This is an example of problem
evolution and solution evolution.
Now that the problem has evolved,
you may come up with a new solution for
the processor design.
This now is an example of problem
evolution and solution evolution.
>> So for an example that might hit
a little bit closer to home for
many of you, as you've been
designing your agents that can solve
the Raven's test, you've done
a process somewhat like this.
You started with some specifications,
general specifications, that your agent
must be able to solve as many problems
on the Raven's test as possible.
You then start with an abstract solution
of just a general problem solving
process that you may have then refined
to be more specific about the particular
transformations to look for or
the particular problem
solving methods to use.
That got you to your final result.
But when you ran your file result, you
may have found something like it would
work but it would take a very,
very long time to run, weeks or months.
So that then causes you to
revise your specifications.
You not only need an agent that can
solve as many problems as possible, but
you also need one that can
solve it in minutes or
seconds instead of weeks or months.